[Musique]
quoi lire cet été et bien on va suivre
les conseils de Stéphanie férial bonjour
bonjour vous êtes libres à la librairies
du canal et vous êtes très
astucieusement avec 5 livres de poche
voilà comme ça on supprime pas et on
passe des moments fabuleux vous avez
sélectionné voilà 5 clips qui vous ont
marqué je suppose
en fait des sujets un peu différents qui
fait que c'est un petit peu pour tout le
monde assez éclectique donc je pense que
tout le monde y trouvera au moins un
pour cet été alors on va commencer avec
un livre qui est
c'est pas hors du temps peut-être je
sais pas comment on dit dans le temps
qui est étonné de Stefano Massimi qui
s'appelle des frères Lehmann alors quand
on dit les frères Lehmann comme ça bon
on se dit qu'est-ce que ça peut être des
frères neiman et puis si on traduit en
train de dire ça pas le même Brothers
économique de 2008 etc et c'est ça en
effet c'est tout à fait ça c'est même
plus que ça parce que on part carrément
de 1844
et ils arrivent aux Amériques comme on
disait encore à cette époque là avec
surtout la volonté de pouvoir vivre
mieux c'est pas le temps de faire
fortune mais c'est de vivre mieux
sauf que ces gars là ils ont dû faire
ils arrivent à New York
on est en 1840 1850 tout est en train de
se faire la ville aussi et c'est des
gars qui ont du flair qui ont de
l'audace et en fait on va suivre avec
eux donc juste en 2008 effectivement
avec la chute
c'est une vraie épopée familiale c'est
vraiment ça la construction tout
simplement d'une ville à construction
d'un pays et la construction de de de ce
qui va être effectivement une fortune
mais également une fortune
internationale c'est ça qui est
extrêmement intéressant
[Musique]
tout simplement
c'est écrit en fait en champ libre comme
avaient fait fuentinos avec Charlotte ou
comme avait fait Joseph Pontus avec à la
ligne donc en fait c'est pas du tout un
alexandrin donc c'est lisible très
facilement
c'est peu utilisé effectivement en
littérature par contre ça donne un
rythme à se manger génial il y a c'est
assez fort c'est assez dynamique et
surtout pour le sujet qui est là je
trouve que c'est ça correspond tout à
fait au sujet ce kaki capitaliste est en
train de se faire cette ville de New
York est en train de se faire en plus il
y a un humour il y a une un folklore
juif tout le long du roman vraiment ça
se termine d'ailleurs par un caddiche
tout simplement enfin en 2008 très
souvent moi les lectures j'avais
l'impression d'être dans un tableau de
Chagall avec cette s'éclosion de couleur
si vous savez c'est marié qui sont là il
y a à la fois du rêve de la magie et
puis quelque chose de très concret est
très réaliste comme voilà ils vont
effectivement donner un peu de sous à
quelqu'un qui veut faire du chemin de
fer et personne n'y croit et eux ils
disent bah oui tiens pourquoi pas
pourquoi
c'est pareil personne je crois que ce
que ce truc et en fait à chaque fois ils
vont donner ça et du coup le roman est
fait comme ça de façon très très rythmée
et ça donne effectivement une épopée
assez assez extraordinaire moi je me
suis je me suis régalé à lire ça et
finalement
voilà ça les a marqué quoi une phrase
j'ai voulu montrer de l'humanité et la
poésie de la banque ah oui oui
parce qu'on pourrait se dire Brothers au
fond les quoi enfin voilà
[Musique]
par tomber mais au fond il y a oui c'est
une épopée mais justement c'est ce qui
montre aussi c'est comme quoi finalement
à un certain moment ça suffit plus il
faut toujours plus le plus donne
toujours et donne toujours envie du plus
et le pouvoir donne aussi envie du plus
donc c'est je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez spectateurs de Charlot envoyé
Mussolini et Hitler qui sera le plus
haut et puis finalement il tombe en fait
c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est on en
veut toujours plus et puis finalement à
quoi ça sert voilà la loi du capitalisme
c'est toujours aller comme disait
quelqu'un voilà c'est comme si vous êtes
sur un vélo si vous arrêtez vous tombez
quoi
c'est tout à fait ça c'est tout à fait
ça donc les frères lemon donc les
demonsors
alors aujourd'hui c'était une pièce de
théâtre à la base et il en a assez ouais
c'était une pièce de théâtre à la base
il en a fait un roman donc ça a été lu
aussi il y a vous venez voilà et
je sais pas si ça peut être adaptable
mais pourquoi pas mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut le lire en fait je crois qu'au
cinéma ça donne pas grand chose au
théâtre je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
qui a le rythme du théâtre et ça ça je
pense que c'est ça peut être pertinent
et à le lire c'est effectivement un vrai
bonheur de lecture et puis on a vraiment
comme ça une palette effectivement de
l'histoire américaine et de notre
histoire aussi à nous tout à fait
un grand format il était sorti chez
Globe et oui je vois prime d'ici c'est
c'est le prix du meilleur livret
étranger de Sofitel 2018 donc oui oui
tout à fait ouais alors autre alors ça
c'est très différent là on va se
resserrer sur une famille
Bénédicte Bénédicte belle poids
Saint-Jacques
Saint-Jacques c'est cette
Paloma qui hérite à la mort de sa mère
d'une maison dans les Cévennes tout à
fait rien à voir avec Compostelle parce
qu'on a tendance
qui s'appelle Jacques qui est
effectivement d'une bonté qui fait que
on le surnomme le Saint-Jacques
effectivement
au fin fond des Cévennes sa mère vient
de décéder je comprends pas pourquoi sa
mère lui il est que c'est une maison au
début elle veut la vendre puis elle se
dit bah non en fait le site est très
beau donc du coup elle va faire
effectivement appel à beaucoup
d'artisans dans la dans la région dont
ce fameux Jacques qui est qui est
charpentier et menuisier et qui va
l'aider à retaper cette maison et
finalement le message c'est en retapant
cette maison elle va un peu découvrir
qui était sa maman parce qu'elle a pas
bien connue elle était plutôt en froid
d'ailleurs avec elle c'était même assez
dur les rapports qu'elles avaient toutes
les deux et elles avaient décidé enfin
de moins elle Paloma avait coupé les
ponts et du coup elle va un peu partir
sur les traces de l'histoire de sa maman
et son histoire
voilà c'est ça donc moi j'ai aimé parce
que c'est d'abord c'est dans ça se passe
dans les Cévennes et que sevennes c'est
une région qui est absolument enfin qui
est très très belle et les descriptions
d'ailleurs les châtaignerait ah ouais
les châtaigneraies sont très bien
décrites les petits matins aussi à
l'aube ou le crépuscule c'est très
joliment décrit et puis cette kyrielle
de personnage qui sont là un peu
atypiques il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
bienveillance donc ça ça
[Musique]
d'aller se perdre dans les sévères si
vous êtes on sait jamais
là c'est un premier roman je crois de
Dany Erico qui s'appelle la cuillère
alors je raconte très vite puis
c'est on est au Pays de Galles et
surtout son père la dette n'est et du
coup ça va l'emmener jusqu'au fin fond
de la Bourgogne donc elle part en
Bourgogne avec sa petite voiture elle
traverse la Manche
et elle va essayer de découvrir en fait
un peu comme chez belles poids voilà qui
était son père voilà et quel était
l'histoire de son père voilà et cette
cuillère à travers la cuillère
jusqu'au pays de Galles c'est à la fois
il y a beaucoup d'humour l'humour
anglais qu'on aime bien voilà c'est ça
et puis elle est toute jeune elle a une
vingtaine d'années elle a beaucoup
beaucoup d'autodérision l'héroïne moi
c'est ça qui m'a plu aussi elle arrive
beaucoup d'humour elle parle un peu
français mais du coup ce que j'ai aimé
aussi c'est qu'elle fait beaucoup de
différences sur la langue elle traduit
parfois littéralement certaines choses
où elle essaye de comprendre des
expressions typiquement Françoise
française pardon et qu'elle essaye de
comprendre de maîtriser elle rencontre
des gens qui sont assez atypiques
jusqu'à un château en Bourgogne donc la
Bourgogne c'est aussi un une belle
région
voilà ça m'a plu aussi un peu comme pour
Saint-Jacques cette histoire de
transmission tout simplement voilà tout
à fait voilà à travers la cuillère
évidemment
[Musique]
toi oui beaucoup d'humour plus légère
les rigolotes avec sa voiture parce que
évidemment elle conduit voilà elle est
complètement paniquée elle comprend rien
de ce qu'elle doit faire arriver en
France donc voilà c'est plus drôle
qu'autre chose mais elle est très
attachante et il y a plein de
personnages aussi et très très
attachants sur en sorte un peu un road
trip vous voyez un road trip en France
c'est un premier roman et que et assez
réussi je trouve pour un premier roman
c'était chez Yana Lévy
voilà qui traduit beaucoup beaucoup de
d'Italiens enfin beaucoup d'italien et
puis aussi des anglaises des Américains
il y a aussi pas mal de français bien
sûr
française
toujours en poche chez Piccolo alors on
continue notre voyage en France on va
aller dans le Lot
avec avec un auteur je connais
la nature humaine c'est le livre qui lui
avait d'ailleurs valu le Prix féminin
et là on est on est ah oui se souvenir
de 1999 de la tempête oui ça c'est la
ouais ouais tout à fait on va suivre
effectivement Alexandre et sa famille on
est au pied du Larzac dans le Lot comme
vous avez dit
un endroit paumé oui tout à fait tout à
fait un endroit un peu paumé
et on va suivre cette famille et cette
cette maison enfin cette ferme avec ses
terres de à peu près
la vache folle là au début des années 80
c'était 80-83 je me souviens plus très
très bien effectivement jusqu'au début
des années 2000 jusqu'à la tempête 90
voilà c'est ça donc on a voilà oui tout
à fait donc on a à peu près plus de 25
ans comme ça de vie de cette famille
avec Alexandre qui un peu malgré lui
donc c'est le benjamin de la famille un
peu malgré lui il va va reprendre la
terre familiale malgré lui parce que
finalement c'est soeur est née n'est
qu'elles ont pu elles ont fait des
études et elles sont partis parce que
finalement reprend la ferme c'était trop
compliqué c'est trop dur et c'est vrai
que c'est un métier qui est pas
forcément facile quoi donc c'est lui qui
la reprend et on va suivre toutes les
évolutions justement que le monde paysan
et le monde agricole a connu après la
vache folle déjà la vache folle et puis
après toutes les directives qui peuvent
être positives ou négatives ça dépend
comment on les vit d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la terre et qui complique ces
habitudes qui fait que pour fond c'est
un monde une sorte de monde qui
disparaît quoi
le fond du livre oui tout à fait et
d'ailleurs il y a un des personnages
voisins de la ferme qui lui est ancré
dans la terre j'adore ce personnage je
me souviens plus du prénom et qui est
très justement encore très tradition et
très vieille vieille tradition et à
garder pourquoi mettre des éoliennes
pourquoi voir des tracteurs qui sont
ultra puissants et ultra voilà alors
qu'alexan lui est un peu un pied entre
les deux voilà entre garder
effectivement une tradition mais
également ce moderniser tout simplement
aussi pour mieux vivre en fait le débat
qui traverse tout le monde de l'école
aujourd'hui complètement tout à fait où
est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'où il faut
aller dans la modernité jusqu'où il faut
aller préserver la nature
comment on peut faire pour préserver la
nature et vivre quand même enfin c'est
toutes ces questions qui qui se posent
et c'est vrai que
cette France qui a été un pays agricole
pendant pendant des siècles des siècles
elle a un peu abandonnée
est originaire du Lot lui-même vient
d'un milieu enfin je crois agricole et
on sent vraiment l'amour de la nature et
l'amour de la terre mais vraiment de la
Terre elle-même de ce qu'elle le respect
aussi la terre de ce qu'elle donne de ce
qu'elle peut donner jusqu'où elle peut
donner quitte à mettre des terres
parfois en jachère même si pendant un an
ou deux c'est peut-être des vaches mecs
il faut manger mais au contraire c'est
aussi la respecter et on le sent
énormément dans ce personnage qui sont
d'une profonde humanité qui sont d'une
bienveillance incroyable et c'est vrai
que Alexandre est un est un héros moi
qui qui reste j'ai lu depuis longtemps
en 2020
donc ça fait trois ans
en plus il est il est fou amoureux d'une
jeune femme constance qui est qui est
allemande qui voit pas tout le monde
tout le temps enfin qui est pas
forcément non plus en France et voilà il
est capable de laisser beaucoup de
choses rien que pour elle et ça ça m'a
touché évidemment
mais pas que ça c'est aussi vraiment
j'en cours il y a toujours des
personnages très en revanche très
gourmand vous voyez cette gourmandise de
la terre des autres de la vie tout
simplement et ça ressort énormément dans
ces dans ces textes et il en sort un
justement pour la rentrée littéraire là
en août qui est qui s'appelle chaleur
humaine et qui est un peu le
prolongement de nature humaine qui sont
les 20 ans après et qui est notamment
aussi pendant le covid et
oui qui sont quasiment les mêmes
personnages enfin ce sont les mêmes les
mêmes prénoms donc oui on se dit oui
voilà
il y a quelque chose de gourmand
oui oui tout à fait moi j'aime bien et
c'est pareil les descriptions de la
nature les descriptions des des animaux
aussi le respect qu'il y a c'est c'est
assez puissant voilà alors
vous avez adoré oui oui d'Olivier qui
s'appelle dans les brumes de caprence
c'est très bien
n'aura qu'il avait un héros récurrent
une trilogie code 93 c'est un flic un
code 93 territoire et surtension et à la
fin de surtension il abandonnait tout et
il partait on savait pas très bien où
entre temps il y a eu d'autres livres
avec d'autres héros
et là on le retrouve avec bonheur il est
sur une petite île perdue au sud de
Terre-Neuve dans les brumes enfin c'est
vraiment c'est balayé par les vents de
l'Atlantique enfin je pense que doit pas
être très très facile d'y vivre en tout
cas
voilà c'est ça et en fait il est chargé
d'un programme de de protection de
témoin d'essayer de tout simplement de
façonner une nouvelle identité pour des
témoins qui sont qui sont protégés qu'il
faut protéger voilà c'est ça donc voilà
il leur apprend entre guillemets avec le
témoin une nouvelle une nouvelle
identité pour qu'après les personnes
puissent repartir dans une nouvelle vie
tout simplement et là on lui envoie une
jeune fille
qui vient qui ne parle pas qui est très
mutique qui n'arrive pas du tout à se
réadapter et qu'il faut absolument
protéger parce qu'elle a un serial
killer qui essaye de la retrouver parce
qu'elle est elle elle peut elle sait qui
sait elle peut décrire qui laisse on
fait comme elle parle pas c'est plutôt
compliqué
et en fait elle a été pendant une
dizaine d'années sous les enfermés dans
une cave en fait c'est pas la première
qu'il y a qu'il y a que c'est killer
enfermé et ce sera peut-être pas non
plus la dernière donc on a en fait deux
il y a l'enquête donc il y a Coste avec
cette jeune fille qui l'essaye de faire
parler et puis le serial killer on sait
pas du tout qui c'est voilà bien sûr
tout à fait et puis le serial killer
donc chapitre par chapitre mais on sait
absolument pas qui c'est qui lui
comprend qu'il a qu'il a été qui peut
être reconnu et essaye du coup d'aller
éliminer cette jeune fille voilà tout à
fait c'est mener ton bourg battant ce
qui est souvent le cas avec norek
c'est-à-dire que on s'ennuie absolument
pas c'est toujours autant
il y a des il y a des rebondissements
auxquels on s'attend pas du tout alors
vous me direz c'est normal mais des fois
en polar on anticipe certaines choses
et c'est ça qui a absolument génial le
le
serial killer est vraiment frappadingue
qui fera pas dingue voilà c'est pas
dégoulinant mais ça fait pas peur ni
rien du tout c'est pas enfin moi j'y
arrive pas je suis un peu douillette
donc il me faut pas des choses trop
violent non on est pas chez Tarantino
donc c'est pas ça
partout non c'est pas du tout
psychologique voilà c'est du bon
suspense avec des bons rebondissements
et une fin qui est toujours
effectivement assez renversante il avait
fait ça aussi avec surface le roman
précédent qui était tout aussi bon et
tout aussi a le temps et où sans
comprendre ce qui va se passer et tout
de suite ah ouais c'était ça voilà
j'aime bien les polars quand ils sont
comme ça ah oui tout à fait il y en
aurait qui c'est vraiment il faire c'est
vraiment effectivement il a cette patte
de savoir nous tenir par le bout du nez
voilà c'est ça tout simplement quoi que
ce soit non voilà tout simplement
Olivier doré dans les brumes de Caplan
et c'est aux éditions
parce que je crois que voilà on a cinq
livres là qu'on peut porter on a de quoi
le dire pendant tout l'été tout à fait
le choix est là
avec plaisir oui oui j'ai commencé en
lire et il y a des il y a des jolies
choses qui se qui se dessine oui tout à
fait voilà merci beaucoup je rappelle
que vous êtes libres à la librairie du
canal du canal
Montigny à Montigny
tout à fait merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]